Tyrion Lannister has some of the best lines
in Game of Thrones.
He can be wise and funny and tragic and cruel,
sometimes all at once.
It’s part of why he’s such a popular character.
But Tyrion’s big mouth has often gotten
him into trouble.
He’s pissed off a lot of people, and one
theory suggests that someday, someone will
shut Tyrion up for good – by cutting out
his tongue.
Lots of people in Game of Thrones have their
tongues removed.
Ilyn Payne had his tongue cut out for talking
smack about the Mad King , and Marillion in
the show loses his for a singing a song . In
the books, Varys makes his little birds mute
, taking the tongues from these children so
they keep his secrets.
Euron Greyjoy cuts out the tongues of the
crew of his ship , and others . And some Bolton
men lose their tongues . So sometimes it’s
about punishment, sometimes about keeping
secrets, sometimes it’s just cruelty and
control.
Lots of tongues come out for lots of reasons
– and some readers think Tyrion will be
next.
Because Tyrion frequently gets threatened
with having his tongue cut out.
Cersei and Joffrey and JonCon and Jorah and
Kurleket all threaten his tongue at some point.
Both Bronn and Oberyn say that someone will
“cut it out one of these days” , and Tyrion
jokes he should do it himself, cause it causes
such trouble . So we’ve got all these direct
hints that someone will cut out Tyrion’s
tongue, and there are a few suspects who seem
especially likely.
Cersei is weirdly obsessed with cutting out
tongues – she mentions the idea in about
half of her chapters . And Cersei deeply hates
Tyrion – she blames him for the death of
Joffrey, and is convinced that he’ll kill
her because of a prophecy . She’s especially
always hated the way he makes fun of her – his
mockery and criticism undermines her power
and pride.
So if Cersei ever has Tyrion at her mercy
in the books, it’d totally fit for her to
finally silence her hated brother.
Another possibility relates to the conspiracy
of Varys and Illyrio.
In the books, there’s this kid called Young
Griff who Varys claims is Aegon Targaryen.
Varys and Illyrio wanna put this Aegon on
the throne . But Tyrion seems to suspect that
the boy may not be a real Targaryen . Many
readers believe this Aegon is actually a Blackfyre
– go watch the Varys video.
But the point is that Tyrion may learn a secret
that Varys doesn’t want getting out.
And since Varys already has a habit of removing
tongues from people to keep his secrets – it’s
totally plausible that Varys or Illyrio might
cut out Tyrion’s tongue to protect their
conspiracy . A third possibility is Euron.
Tyrion hasn’t met Euron in the books yet,
but Euron is becoming a big bad guy, and he
cuts out lotsa tongues, so he might be a suspect
also.
So it’s a strong possibility that Tyrion
may lose his tongue.
And this could fit really well with the character
arcs of Tyrion’s family.
At the start of the story, Tyrion’s brother
Jaime is defined by his ability to fight with
a sword . That is his source of power and
pride and identity – until in Book 3, his
hand is cut off, and Jaime has to redefine
who he is . “Who am I now?” he asks . Similarly,
Tyrion’s sister Cersei draws her power and
pride from her beauty and status , which is
symbolically stripped from her in this walk
of shame . So there’s this pattern of Lannisters
losing what gives them their pride and power.
And the equivalent of Jaime’s hand is Tyrion’s
tongue.
Cersei says that Tyrion wields “words as
skillfully as Jaime wields a sword” . If,
like Jaime, Tyrion’s weapon is cut from
him, he’ll also have to redefine who he
is.
Without a tongue, his passions for conversation,
politics, even food and sex, will be affected
– the meaning of his life will be at threat.
This is a brutal thing to do to a character,
but author George Martin does it over and
over not only with Jaime and Cersei, but with
Bran, and Arya, and Theon.
Bran loves to climb and ride, so George breaks
his back.
Arya relies on her sight to survive, so George
blinds her.
Theon uses sex to feel less insecure, so George
castrates him.
When these characters lose what defines them,
they are forced to evolve – into a tree
god, a dark assassin, a hollow ghost.
It’s “growth then decay, then transformation”
– and it makes for great storytelling.
So Tyrion losing his tongue would fit not
only all the threats he’s received, and
the motivations of his enemies, and the pattern
in the Lannister family, but the author’s
overall strategy of breaking characters down
to see what they’re made of and what they
can become.
Alt Shift X makes videos using Adobe After
Effects.
It’s taken years to develop this unusual
style of editing, and there’s always more
to learn and improve.
For this vid, we tried making our motion smoother
using this tutorial on Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning site with
thousands of classes on design, writing, business,
marketing, breathing(?), and video production.
There’s really high-quality material here,
and Skillshare has a nice community vibe of
people learning and building things together.
So if you want to learn a new skill – or
improve on an old one – whether for work,
or just for fun – check out Skillshare at
the link below.
As our sponsor, they’re offering a two month
free trial to first 500 people to sign up.
This helps support Alt Shift X, and helps
you learn something new.
Thanks.
If you want to read more about the idea of
Tyrion losing his tongue, you might like to
read this Reddit post by Hamfast42 , and others.
Thanks to the Patrons, including Austin Ing,
Gabriel Maximus Mount, Heather Nealon-Champagne,
Walter Pope Hunter IV, and spacebawl1.
Cheers.